me
さっきから中学生がずっと家の外ではじめ雪外れ者ちょっと叫んでおります
うふ
右やがったか見えガッター
殺さもう止まんだけ
あのなんか普通にもうめんどくさいからスルー吸ったり吐いとかしてたんですけども
さすがに酷すぎるあのーなんだろうなまあ家に来ることもダメなんですけども家の
ちょっとで叫ばれるとボクじゃなくてその周りの人に迷惑になるわけじゃないですか
あの
あまりひどいようですとも訪う子供もかかわらず通報します
きっとだよねいつマリアの骨格住んでる人に迷惑かかるのは本当に僕いやなんであまり
にひどいよだったら僕もしっこさなきゃいけなくなりますしそもそも何かそーゆーめー
わくコー s タイプ非常にダメだと思うしダメなことはダメなんでそれ一本
ています
dee
あっちゃー逃げたじゃん
超逃げた山町2桁長に出た笑って逃げていけなかったと同情ねーなーに報えな話あげれ
ばいいのに
ほんとせっかく撮るならを話しかけてくるくらいしてもいいね
対応しないけど姉ための坊主だったら野球部ですよ
ですが三大大大大大ガチャりがとうございます
そいつらもいた c それとは別に野球部の3人集団が縁で
でなんかを見つかったら全力でニングってくるっていう
テープでで言ってちょっとおいでおいでみたら神崎た瞬間頭だけのレッスン
you do
腹あまりざああのーーー
近所の人のファー迷惑になるから声出せないでああ
逃げていったぞ
姉アウェイな小学生土地代衆望でございますあれ友達へ
違う
めっちゃ叫んでない
じゃないなぁ通報だなこれは
のファンです
ちょっと2位してくるは今からん下がってがあり方だ
いやあんまりこのれると止め役しちゃうから
また待つとかだったらはずけど
荒れてるのはいいんだけど叫ばれるのだけはほんとにちょっと
関数起こっていポリオちょっとやばいよねでも
始め
始めが悪質なぁ
もしもし今公演の特にいるんですよ
ダメ叫んでるこっちがう
お前らべる濡らしてるの
前
ホーム時世よ
なんで鳴らす店のアナウンサー俺だけじゃなくてさぁ
周りの人の迷惑になるからさあと始めた叫んでた奴誰を選んでは読めば次のねこれ
あんまり酷いようだと警察に言わなきゃいけなくなるからはちょっと怖いこっちこ
お前もいいと言うな何でもとキター入っちゃいけません
この2つって4年前の書いてください何時と
ん
いやーもうなんか来ないグルじゃなくてやったことに対してだかなぁ
いや俺たちいいんだけど
この人ですからまだ叫んでんサーの底だっ来るまで待つ
なんでまた来たて買う
のび犬って
台座に教えたの
あずれ冊を抜ければよくあるぞ
んんん
いやーさすがに今回ひどいよ
やりすぎさせ金周りに迷惑かけたために所は強い
ちょっと i さげなやつ
誰だけどなぁ
お祝いちゃんがした訳じゃ
をなすりつけるなやチャリチャリもさうるせえーじゃあねなんでビルついてると思う
そう危ない時にベルならせるんだよ
今日はそういう時に何か
家の周りとかにならされると迷惑じゃんでみんなの
どうぞああございましたん
ありがとうございます
なんで音を鳴らすため持つ本当に拡大したいなら a novel 押せば良くなるか
なかったら叫ぶの家でも外でちょっと来ないで補正
迷惑してるわけよ他の人がで周りの人が今度来たら本当に多分2走術 c 学校にも
有する女に女はかけないように
分かった
奄美酷いから
ん早6
me
あっはぁ
入ってゆけで家の周りだ暴れまくってた中学生を注意して説教したわけなんですけども
僕がこの動画で言いたいことは下に来るなっていうことも引退5それ自体も駄目ですし
そうなると僕たちの方に苦情が来くるんですよ
僕たちの方に丸の人から国家状がきちゃった僕は誰がどう言おうとその家を出ないと
いけなくなるんでいろんなことを相談したり理解してもらえ
すごい仲良くして下さる大家さんもいるしそう関この家から出たくないんですよという
のもあってですね
今回はとんでもない奴が言ったんでこの趣味たぞというところでございます本当に
ひどかったり
これじゃ人が来ると僕引っ越すん手当等ある方は普通に警察にも通報いたしますので
なぜあの近所の人とかには迷惑をかけないでほしいですという話でござい
いますすごい地帯上座とてもわかるんですけど
来れば来るほど僕はう
静岡にいなくなっちゃうよっていう話ですますごいきたい気持ちはわかるんですけども
割礼に来たや晴れられたりするとねこれは
酒造がを出なきゃいけなくなるよっていう話です
まぁこれでわかってくれたら僕は満足で多分これもね
同い年だったら同じことしてると思うよ動きをつけてじゃない